Just three feet of added sea level...
...will eliminate up to 14,000 square feet of the Indian subcontinent.
So a rise of 70 times that would be disastrous for the region.
Mumbai and Calcutta would be underwater along with the entire country of Bangladesh,...
...which is home to 160 million people.
The coast of Southeast Asia and the surrounding islands will be pushed inland,...
...drowning Bangkok, Ho Chi Minh City, Singapore, Manila and Hong Kong.
Land that's currently home to 600 million Chinese would disappear underwater,...
...wiping out Shanghai and Beijing.
Sea level in Japan will rise 10 to 20% faster than the global average.
After all is said and done,...
...hundreds of millions of people will be forced to retreat inland,...
...leaving behind the continent's largest and most prosperous cities...
...to be buried by the ocean.